so today we're talking about call of
duty finally revealing details about its
anti-cheat system how fifa is asking ea
for one billion dollars
as well as the ghost recon frontlines
beta being delayed my name is devonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news
let's start with the call of duty update
as activision has finally revealed the
details for the new anti-cheat system on
october 13th activision announced that
call of duty will be able to better
combat cheaters with the upcoming
ricochet anti-cheat system the publisher
describes this as a quote multifaceted
approach to combat cheating featuring
new server side tools with monitor
analytics to identify cheating enhanced
investigation processes to stamp out
cheaters updates to strengthen account
security and more
players can expect the ricochet
anti-cheat security features to launch
alongside call of duty vanguard on
november 5th these new security features
will also arrive with the vanguard
themed pacific map coming to call of
duty war zone later in the year
and now let's switch gears from some cod
news to some oh my god that is a lot of
money news the new york times reports
that ea and fifa have been in
negotiations for at least two years
about the future of the video game
series which the site reports has
brought in more than 20 billion for ea
over the past 20 years the series has
paid dividends for fifa 2 which makes
about 150 million per year from ea's
games due to its licensing agreement
according to the report fifa wants quote
more than double what it is currently
getting from ea and is asking for 1
billion for each 4 year world cup cycle
ea's existing deal with fifa gives it
the right to use fifa's name and logo in
the game and also to include the world
cup outside of the financial
considerations fifa and ea can't find
common ground on what the overall rights
package should include according to the
report fifa is seeking to limit its
exclusivity deal with ea to the football
game alone and ea is apparently looking
to expand its rights arrangement to also
include things like showing real game
highlights and selling nfts among other
things
and now let's move on to some
unfortunate news following last week's
reveal of ghost recon frontline and the
extremely mixed reaction from shooter
fans ubisoft has announced that the
closed testing period for the game has
been delayed indefinitely if you didn't
know frontline is a large-scale pvp
shooter that aims to honor the
franchise's tactical legacy while
transitioning to a first person
multiplayer shooter experience 100
players on teams of three try to find
intel and extract it while facing off
against the other teams the game was
announced as a part of ubisoft's 20th
anniversary ghost recon stream and its
trailer was ratioed hard by viewers with
over 17 000 dislikes compared to 5 000
likes and as of this recording the
reason for the delay is still unknown
and speaking of delays solar ash has
been pushed from october 26 to december
2nd on twitter heart machine announced
that itself and annapurna interactive
need quote a bit more time to get the
last pieces of polish and bug fixes into
the game
and now let's talk about free stuff
because who doesn't love free stuff to
celebrate the psvr's fifth birthday
playstation has announced that it will
give away a trio of playstation vr games
to ps plus members in november the
freebies will be in addition to the
regular monthly lineup which typically
includes a ps5 game and two ps4 games so
subscribers will get six games in total
playstation hasn't revealed which psvr
games will be for free but we imagine
they will be notable titles given the
occasion and remember you can and
totally should claim these games even if
you don't have a psvr because if you get
one
this current one or the one that they're
currently developing
you'll already have games to play so why
not i've done that with psvr i used to
do that back in the day with vita like
why not i even did it with ps5
free games
but comment down below and let me know
what you think of the new ricochet
anti-cheat system and if you think it is
going to save call of duty is it going
to save warzone
and make it the very best battle royale
than it can be in the history of battle
royales
let me know
you